ARCHULETA AT KANSAS STATE
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD CABRERO
CORTESE DALLY DODD THE RISER
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO JONES.
CAM AUGER LAYERED LLEVA THE
MOON REQUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT SHOW OF BOTH
HANDS POURTANT TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER. STERN AMBERG BY CAL
SKI WINNER WELL. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING A QUORUM IS PRESENT
GOOD FRIDAY MORNING IT'S A
GREAT BEAUTIFUL DAY TO DO THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS IN THE STATE
SENATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST B. ON THE
RAIL AND THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY SENATOR ARCH
ALETTA AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR GROVE. CENTER
ACTUALLY. THANK YOU PRESIDENT.
PLEASE BOW YOUR HEADS. GRACIOUS
AND MERCIFUL GOD WE LIVE THIS
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND IN MEMORY
OF ALL DEAD WHO GAVE THEIR
LIVES IN ANY WAR. IN MEMORY OF
THOSE WHO SURVIVED BUT REMAINED
BROKEN IN BODY MIND OR SOUL. IN
MEMORY OF A SERMON ON THE MOUNT.
THAT BLESS THE PEACEMAKERS AND
THOSE WHO MOURN. IN MEMORY OF
THE ACTIVISTS AND THE ARTISTS
WHO IMPRISONED AND KILLED OR
WHO WERE PRESENT AND KILLED FOR
THE STAND THEY TOOK FOR JUSTICE.
IN MEMORY OF ALL THE TEACHERS
WHO SAID IN A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT WAYS. BRING PEACE AND
LIGHT WHEREVER YOU GO. IN
MEMORY OF THE CHILDREN WHO NEED
US NOW TO GROW UP AND GET AND
GET ALONG. IN MEMORY OF THE
EARTH. AND OUR FELLOW CREATURES
WHO COUNT ON US TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT. IN MEMORY OF EACH OF US
WAKING UP SLOWLY TO THE MIRACLE
OF OUR OWN LIVES. IN. IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. YEAH ALL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WOULD YOU PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR JUST A
MOMENT WE'RE GOINGTO RESERVE
MEMORIAL DAY WITH A MOMENT OF
SILENCE MEMBERS THIS WEEKEND WE
OBSERVE MEMORIAL DAY ORIGINALLY
KNOWN AS DECORATION DAY. JADED
IN THE YEARS FOLLOWING THE
CIVIL WAR. AND DIDN'T BECOME AN
OFFICIAL FEDERAL HOLIDAY UNTIL
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. MEMORIAL
DAY GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HONOR THE SOLDIERS AIRMEN
MARINES NAVY AND GUARDSMEN. WHO
GAVE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE FOR
OUR NATION. WE PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN HONOR
OF ALL THOSE WHO HAVE DIED IN
THE SERVICE OF OUR COUNTRY. WE
SALUTE ALL THOSE WHO GAVE. AND
WE WILL NOT FORGET THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE ANY MEMBERS
TO TAKE UP WHARFS REMOVE BILLS
AND CONSENT. TO THE AN ACTIVE
FILE- OR FROM THE NECK TO FILE
RETURN THE BILL TO SIMPLY FOR
FURTHER ACTION. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED ON MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SINNER DIED.
ANYBODY ELSE IT WILL NEED TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR THE INACTIVE
FILE. SENATOR DIED YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SINNER DIED WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SENATOR I'M BERG
CENTER NUMBER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHT EIGHT SP
SIX SIX SIX TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ALSO MR PRESIDENT PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
FIVE ONE S. B FORTY NINE FROM
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SARAH BURKE
CENTER DOT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS MOVE S. B. TWENTY
FIVE A LOT OF NUMBER SEVENTY
ONE OF THE NOT THE FATHER.
THANK YOU SIR DOT CENTER
FLORENTINO. UNDER MOTIONS IN
ROWS OF RED RESOLUTIONS PLEASE
MOVE SP THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. I
DON'T KNOW THE FILE NUMBER SP
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU SIR
PARDON TINA. MEMBERS ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED
FOR MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
AND FOR INACTIVE FILE. GIVE IT
ONE MORE SKIABLE SECONDS. ONE
MOMENT. JUST AS A REMINDER ON
YOUR MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IF
ANY SENATOR NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED. SENATOR STERN I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LIKE TO
REMOVE OFTEN SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM. ONE NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU ADAM ONE NINETY TWO.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT MIGHT
CONCLUDE. ONE- THIS. THANK YOU
SIR STERN. OKAY LADIES GERMAN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY AND SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE WE'RE GONNA
TAKE UP ITEM TWENTY TWO FIRST.
WHEN WE GET TO THAT CHANGE.
SENATOR STERN ON ITEM TWENTY
TWO SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTEEN
ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT SIR.
SINISTER AND HAS THE FLOOR.
SENSOR I'M MY APOLOGIES.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. NOW SINNERS
YOUR TURN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CERTAIN BIT RESTING
HERE- I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
IS B. THREE SEVENTEEN. THE
CRITICAL BILLING ENSURING.
ATTENTION TO MENTAL HEALTH
EQUITY IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM
CURRENTLY WE'RE USING OUR
COUNTY JAILS AS MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FACILITIES ALL TOO
OFTEN. AND UNDER EXISTING LAW
INCOMPETENT DEFENDANTS CAN ONLY
RECEIVED TIME SERVED CREDIT FOR
GOOD CONDUCT WE NEED IN THE
COUNTY JAIL BUT NOT WHEN THEY
SPENT TIME IN OTHER TREATMENT
FACILITIES. HELLO WHEN
DEFENDANTS ARE CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR- THE LAW DOES NOT
PROVIDE ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND THEIR FREE TALC TRY THE
TENSION OFTEN SPENT WAITING IN
JAIL. FOR A TREATMENT BED. SB
THREE SEVENTEEN ENSURES THAT
INCOMPETENT DEFENDANTS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SAME TIME
SERVED CREDIT FOR GOOD CONDUCT
AS THEY'RE COMPETENT
COUNTERPARTS. WHILE RECEIVING
TREATMENT IN ANY TREATMENT
FACILITY OR AS AN OUTPATIENT.
THIS WILL PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR DEFENDANTS
CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANORS
INSTEAD OF BEING RELEASED FOR
ADEQUATE TREATMENT. HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERED THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVE OPTION. NOT ALL
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE FOR EVERY
DEFENDANT HOWEVER. THERE DEPEND
ON THE SITUATION AND STATUS OF
EACH DEFENDANT. THIS TAILORED
APPROACH WILL GIVE EXISTING
TOOLS TO HELP DEFENDANTS GAIN
COMPETENCY AND AVOID A CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION WE KEEP WINNING
ON OUR COUNTY JAILS AS MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITIES. AND NOT
DOING THE JOB THEY SHOULD BE
DOING WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
MEMBERS EITHER IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON FILE AND TWENTY TWO. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA I AT KINS
BASE. BACKER. HI FORGES.
BRADFORD HI BYRON HI COURTESY
HI DALLY HI TODD. HI TORONTO I
HAVEN HI GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH HI HERTZBERG I WAS
SO HI HER TADO HI JONES. NO CAN
LONGER HI LAYERED HI LABOUR HI
THE MON. MCGUIRE RIGHT HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A SHOW BOTH HI PAM.
FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI NUMBER
ALL RIGHT HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I AT
KINS BASE NO GORGEOUS. THE MON.
CAN. HI WHATEVER EYES THIRTY
TWO KNOWS FIVE MAJOR PASSES.
TAKING UP NEXT WELL ITEM THIRTY
THREE CENTRES TURN ARE YOU ALSO
READY FOR ITEM FILE THIRTY
THREE. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO FIRE PREVENTION. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT OUR MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT IT AS B. SIXTY THREE
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A FIRE
RESILIENCY AND VOLUNTEER CORPS
IMPROVE BUILDING STANDARDS- AND
GET OUR STATE. BACK ON TRACK
FOR A NEW MODERN APPROACH TO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THIS IS A
CRITICAL PIECE O THE SENATE'S
WILDFIRE PACKAGE WHICH WE
UNVEILED YESTERDAY WITH THE
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE IS
ALSO RE INTRODUCTION OF A BILL
THAT UNFORTUNATELY DIED AT THE
LEVIN TO OUR SESSION LAST YEAR.
AND NEVER RECEIVED A VOTE
HOWEVER THE BILL AS A UNIQUE
COALITION- BEHIND IT- FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS- TO FIRE
PROTECTION AND FIRE CHIEFS THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY OUR
UTILITIES- REALTORS- THE SIERRA
CLUB. AND A NUMBER OF OTHERS
WHO ALL AGREE THAT WE HAVE TO
IMPROVE OUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
MANAGEMENT WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
TREATMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO
FIRE PREVENTION AROUND OUR
ROADWAYS THOSE OF YOU DRIVE
AROUND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIANS
THE MUSTARD. AND ALL THAT
BEAUTIFUL YELLOW THAT WILL
BECOME GRASS SOON AND BURN OUR
COMMUNITIES DOWN WE'RE ALSO
ENHANCING BUILDING STANDARDS IN
ALL AREAS OF FIRE RISK AND MOST
IMPORTANT OF ALL EMPOWERING
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OUR
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS THE TRAIN
VOLUNTEERS IN FIRE PREVENTION.
IT'S IMPORTANT STEP. FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSS OR DEBATE.
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I ALSO WANT TO STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND THANK THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IT IS A SENATE
WHILE FAR WORKING GROUP
PRIORITY. BILL AND I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO VOTE I
THINK HE'S- THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. HI ARCHULETA FIVE AT KINS.
BAIT BY BECKER HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD. I HAVE UNDER EYE
CORTESE HI DALLY I DON. HI THE
RUSSELL HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI- TANTO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA.
HI THE MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN HI
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI HI WINNER.
I WILL HI MEMBERS RIGHT GO TO
THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME US
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS GROVE.
YEAH I LIMONIUM. MELINDA'S HI.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MAJOR PASSES THANK YOU LADIES
IN GERMAN MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
JUMP TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOLLOWED BY SEVENTY TWO AND
SEVENTY THREE- SENATOR ROTH IS
UP ON FILE AND I'M SEVENTY S.
B. EIGHT OH TWO. SENATOR ROB
APPEARS TO BE READY SENATE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH TWO BY SENATOR
ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. THE
ROCK YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SP
EIGHT OH TWO IS THE SUNSET BILL.
RELATED TO THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
AS YOU KNEW AS YOU KNOW WE MOVE
THE SUNSET BILLS BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY AS WE WORK OT THE
DETAILS. THIS BILL CURRENTLY
MAKES VARIOUS TECHNICAL CHANGES
TO THE PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION ACT ADMINISTERED BY
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK- I DON'T.
THANK YOU CENTERS ROB ANY
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
MAJOR PASSES HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR
ROB MOVING TO THIS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO. S. B. THIRTY NINE
SENATOR GROVE. CENTER GROVE
APPEARS TO BE READY SOONER-
SURGERY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
GROVE AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY VERA TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY CENTER
GROVE YOU HAVE THE FLOOR THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SP THIRTY NINE
AIMS TO ADOPT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
TO PROTECT TAXPAYER FUNDS.
WHILE HELPING TO ENSURE THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
ONLY GO TO ELIGIBLE UNEMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS BY MANDATING THAT
THE EDT THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT CONDUCT
REGULAR CROSS MATCHING WITH
THEIR RECORDS WITH DATA
PROVIDED BY THE CDC ARE AT
LEAST EVERY NINETY DAYS. AND
REQUIRES THE DATA TO ONLY
INCLUDE CURRENT INMATES THIS
CALL ALSO REQUIRES THE EDT TO
NOTIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND CDC ARE IF THEY
DISCOVER EVIDENCE OF FRAUD IN
THEIR CROSS MATCHING OVER THE
LAST YEAR EVERYONE OF OUR
OFFICES COLLEAGUES HAD RECEIVED
THOUSANDS OF CALLS FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS ASKING FOR HELP-
RICK TO RECEIVE BENEFITS THAT
THEY SO RIGHTLY DESERVE WHILE
SINGLE MOMS AND FATHERS WERE
FORCED TO DRAIN THEIR SAVINGS
ACCOUNT TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES AND PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLES. FRAUDULENT CLAIMS WERE
AWARDED TO PEOPLE THAT DID NOT
DESERVE THEM AT A TIME THAT
FRAUD DISCOVERED IN CALIFORNIA
THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED SOME SORT
OF FRAUD PREVENTION TO ADDRESS
INMATE SCAMS. I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND BERKLEY FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON TO NARROW
THIS BILL TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE NATURE
OF INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
SHARED BETWEEN THESE TWO
AGENCIES. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN THE RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEES AND THOSE WHO HAVE
JOINED AS CO AUTHORS I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT THIS BIPARTISAN
MEASURE THAT THE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED TO KEEP- FRIDAY OUT
OF R. ET DE SYSTEM IT'S JUST
ONE PART OF IT AND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'LL VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE MEMBERS
WERE GETTING A LITTLE BIT OF
CHATTER ON THE FLOOR IF- YOU
HAVE DISCUSSIONS THAT NEED TO
OUR URGENT AND NEED TO TAKE
PLACE IF YOU COULD PLEASE. I
TAKE THOSE OFF THE FLOOR- AND
SO WE CAN. MAINTAIN DECORUM
HERE ON THE FLOOR. SET A
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR HER TADO YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THE SPILL.
THE POPULATED TDD CLAIMS THAT
WE SAW PLAY OUT LAST YEAR. WAS
UNACCEPTABLE WE MUST DO WHAT WE
CAN TO SAFEGUARD THOSE FUNDS
FOR THOSE THAT ARE TRULY IN
NEED SB THIRTY NINE REQUIRE CDC
ARE SURE NAMES AND SOCIAL
SECURITY OF THEIR INMATES WITH
EDS WE CAN HAVE SUCH AN
INCIDENT- NEVER OCCUR AGAIN.
FOR THIS REASON ASPIRIN I
BOUGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR-
MEMBERS ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE AND I'M SEVENTY
TWO MEMBERS ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
DELI. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO JUST TO SHARE
AS AN EMPLOYER WE NEED TO HAVE
THE ASSURANCE THAT IF IT RUNS
THROUGH THE EMPLOYERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE EMPLOYERS CORRECT
KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
UNEMPLOYED THAT WE WOULD SOLVE
THIS THESE- ABILITIES FOR FRAUD
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SOME OF THE
SAFEGUARDS IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DELHI ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE THIS ITEM QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO YOU USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE THE MAIN-
URGENCY PASSES THIRTY EIGHT
EYES NOSE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES THIRTY EIGHT EYES NOSE
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE.
CENTER I'M BERGEN SENATE BILL
FORTY ONE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND ACTUALLY TO
PRIVACY AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY VERA TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AS P.
FORTY ONE THE GENETIC
INFORMATION PRIVACY ACT WOULD
STRENGTHEN CONSUMERS CONTROL
OVER GENETIC MATERIAL THAT THEY
PROVIDED DIRECT CONSUMER
TESTING COMPANIES BY REQUIRING
THESE COMPANIES TO GET
CONSUMERS CONSENT BEFORE USING
THE GENETIC DATA. FOR ANYTHING
BUT WHAT THE CONSUMER PROVIDED
THEIR CONSENT TO DO ORIGINAL
VOTE THANK YOU SIR ROBERT ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
AND I'M SEVENTY THREE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE LADIES AND JOHN THAT'S
ALSO QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON FILE AND I'M
SEVENTY THREE. AND ALSO ON THE
URGENCY. SEEING NONE. URGENCY
PASSES EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO MAJOR PASSES EYES THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN. OKAY
THAT'S ALSO MISTER AMBERG
CENTER NUMBER SO WE GOT THE
FINAL ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY NINE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. AT ABOUT THREE
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR UMBERG AN
ACT RELATING TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES S. B. THREE FORTY
NINE PM CALIFORNIA ETHICAL
TREATMENT FOR PERSONS WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER ACT
WOULD PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
SEEKING TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS FROM UNSCRUPULOUS
SERVICE PROVIDERS BY ENSHRINING
IN LAW SERIES OF COMMONSENSE
RIGHTS AND BY PROHIBITING
DECEPTIVE ADVERTISING AND
MARKETING PRACTICES. TO KEEP
THESE VULNERABLE PEOPLE FROM
GETTING THE CARE THEY NEED FROM
REPUTABLE PROVIDERS ARE URGING
NOVEL. THANK YOU SIR AMBERG
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS ITEM ALSO QUALIFIES
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL AND FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN. SEEING NONE MAJOR PASSES
EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IS ZERO
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT CENTER CALERO. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY FIVE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR KABBADI
OTTO AND ACTUALLY DID A MEDICAL.
INTERCAMBIO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB THREE SIXTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE MEDICAL TO
REIMBURSE ALL PARTICIPATING
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO OPERATE OUT
OF A FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CLINICOR RURAL HEALTH CLINIC.
FOR E. CONSULT SERVICES THE
SERVICES OF OUR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER TO SEND AN ELECTRONIC
KIND OF CONSULT TO A SPECIALIST
PROVIDER WHEN A PATIENT HAS A
NON URGENT QUESTION OR
CONDITION THAT MIGHT REQUIRE
SPECIALTYCARE. CURRENTLY E.
ECON SALT SERVICES ARE
REIMBURSABLE FOR THE SPECIALIST
PROVIDERS BUT NOT THE PRIMARY
CARE BOTH PROVIDERS ARE
BRINGING EXPERTISE IN
INFORMATION TO THE TABLE WHEN
DISCUSSING THE PATIENT'S
CONDITION. BUT ONLY THE
SPECIALIST CAN BILL FOR THEIR
TIME THIS TYPE OF COMMUNICATION
IS A SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT TO
PATIENTS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
UP BECAUSE OF THE GREATLY
INCREASED ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE- THAT USED TO BE COUNSELED
ALSO DETERMINES AS OF IF A
PHYSICAL VISIT IS NEEDED SAVING
THE PATIENT'S TIME AND MANY
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
IN RURAL AND UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SO IT'S A SMALL CHANGE TO THE
BILLABLE TELEHEALTH SERVICES
AND MEDICAL MOKRI IT WILL NOT
ONLY CREATE EQUITY FOR THE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER PROMOTE
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WILL
IMPROVE CARE FOR THE PATIENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR KABIRU
ANY DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT. ANY
DISCUSSION AND- SEEING NINE
LADIES IN GERMAN THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE AND
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT. SEEING NINE
EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MAJOR
PASSES. ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE. CENTER ADMIN
SP FIVE OH SEVEN. SINNER EGGMAN
IS READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE OH SEVEN BY
ENATOR EDMUND AND AFTER
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND
A MEMBER TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SP FIVE OH SEVEN IT IS A-
REVISIONS TO LAURA'S LOVE TO
CLEAN UP FROM LAST YEAR BASED
ON THE AUDITOR'S REPORT- WHICH
WILL THEN HELP PEOPLE GET INTO
OUT ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR EDMUND ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE. ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
SEEING NONE. BASIN GEMMA'S ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
YOU USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
AND FILE AN EIGHTY THREE.
SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES REASON
JOHN WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON A FILE
ITEM NINETY THREE. SENATOR
SKINNER SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN.
SHE'S GONNA PASS WAS GOING TO
FALL INTO. NINETY SIX. SENATOR
SKINNER ON NINETIES ON UP
SENATE BILL TWENTY SEVEN.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION CENTER SKINNER ON
SENATE BILL TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
THAT'S B. TWENTY SEVEN WILL
HAVE SUPPORT OUR FARMERS AND
OUR LAND MANAGERS. IN MANAGING
THEIR LANDS TO HELP STORE
CARBON FROM THE ATMOSPHERE IN
OUR SOILS CAL IT MAKES
CALIFORNIA MORE RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE IMPACTS AND I'M SURE
MANY OF YOU KNOW. OUR SOILS ARE
IN EFFECT LIVING ENTITIES BANDS
THE MICROORGANISMS IN THE SOIL
CCAP THE CAPACITY TO STORE A
GREAT DEAL OF CARBON IF THEY'RE
MANAGED IN A WAY THAT- DOES
THAT AND SO OBVIOUSLY IT IS ONE
OF THE SIMPLER WAYS TO ADDRESS
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IT'S JUST BY
MAXIMIZING THE ABILITY. OF OUR
SOILS TO STORE CARBON
SPECIFICALLY SP TWENTY SEVEN
DIRECTS OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND OUR AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. TO SET GOALS FOR THIS
SEQUESTRATION FROM NATURAL
WORKING LANDS AND ESTABLISHES A
VOLUNTARY REGISTRY OF
SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS AT THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH. TO BE ABLE TO SO THAT
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT
THAT MAY WANT TO INVEST IN
THESE KIND OF PROJECTS CAN HAVE
THE- THE SECURITY THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE REAL AND ARE
ACTUALLY ACHIEVING WHAT IS
INTENDED. THE FARM BUREAU AT
THECULTURE COUNSEL AND THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ARE NOW
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND WITHOUT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
SENATORS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILING OF NINETY SIX
S. B. TWENTY SEVEN. SENATOR
COME AERO ARE YOU RECOGNIZE
FIRST INTERCAMBIO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAKE PRIVATE DOLLAR
INVESTMENTS FOR OUR HARD
WORKING FARMING AND RANCHING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS
THE STATE FARMERS AND RANCHERS
ARE ADOPTING NEW LAND
MANAGEMENT TECHNIQUES SUCH AS
ADDING COVER CROPS FOR PLANTING
REGENERATIVE COTTON THAT LEAD
TO MULTI BENEFIT ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES. THAT DATA IS CLEAR
THAT NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
STRATEGIES CAN INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF CARBON PULLED FROM
THE ATMOSPHERE IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS. EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVE CLIMATE RESILIENCE THIS
COULD CLIMATE CHANGE SOLUTION
EMBRACES THE ROLE OF FARMERS
RANCHERS AND LAND MANAGERS AS
RESPONSIBLE STEWARDS OF OUR
STATE AND HELPS TO MAINTAIN
OPEN SPACE AND WORKING LANDS AS
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL
HISTORY. AND NECESSARY FUTURE
FOR THESE REASONS I'M PROUD TO
BE A JOINT AUTHOR OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR COME AERO SENATOR DALLY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE AS A- THIRD GENERATION
FARMER SOMEBODY WHO IS- BUT ON
A PIECE OF LAND FOR ALMOST
NINETY YEARS NOW- I WANTED TO
SHARE FOR A MOMENT SOME OF THE
PRACTICES THAT WE USE. WE USE
BIO CHAR WHICH IS- COMES FROM
WOOD WASTE PRODUCTS- AND WE
INCORPORATED INTO OUR SOILS
WHICH IS PUTTING CARBON BACK IN
OUR SCHOOLS HELPING BUILD
ORGANICS BACK IN ARSENAL'S WE
USE COVER CROPS. SUCH AS
AUSTRALIAN FEEL PEACE WHICH ARE
VERY HIGH IN NUTRIENTS FOR THE
SOILS AND WE TELL THOSE BACK IN
FACT- TODAY TRACTORS RUNNING IN
OUR FIELDS DOING THAT RIGHT
NOW. THERE ARE FARMERS- DO A
LOT IN THE AREA WE TALK ABOUT
CARBON SEQUESTRATION AND WE
OFTEN DON'T THINK ABOUT. ALL
THE LAND THAT IS USED FOR
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
A GREAT START I THINK IT'S A
GOOD TOOL TO EDUCATE ON HOW I A
CALIFORNIA FARMERS ARE LEADING
THE WAY IN DOING A GOOD JOB OF
PROTECTING OUR SOILS-
PRODUCING. THE FOOD AND FIBER
THAT WE NEED- TO FEED AMERICA
AND THE WORLD AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I STAND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR DALLY ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON SB
TWENTY SEVEN ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUT SANDERS CAN WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I. ATKINS.
BASE I BECKER. I FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI WE'RE
TESTING HI DALLY. I DON. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG BY WAY SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAMELOT- I
LAYERED I LABOR. I THE MON.
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. NO MAN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI AMBER ALL RIGHT I LIKE
ASKING. FIVE WINNER I WILL.
HIGHS THIRTY FOUR NOES THREE
MAJOR PSSES AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S GONNA
WANNA GO BACK TO FIVE NINETY
THREE WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
FILE IT IN NINETY THREE CENTER
SCANNER ON S. B. EIGHTEEN.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ACTUALLY BEING TO
ENERGY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP EIGHTEEN
DEALS WITH HYDROGEN WHICH IS
THE MOST BASIC ELEMENT IN THE
UNIVERSE. AND WHICH IF WE
UTILIZE THE HYDROGEN THAT IS
PRODUCED IN A MANNER THAT IS
LOW CARBON HAS THE ABILITY TO
HELP US MOVE OR DECARBONISE
WHILE PRESERVING MANY OF OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
JOBS RELATED TO THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO SP EIGHTEEN
ADVANCES GREEN HYDROGEN BY
REQUIRING OR AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES
START PLANNING SO THE
CALIFORNIA CAN FULLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF GREEN HYDROGEN AND
THE DO YOU THINK ABOUT HYDROGEN
IS THAT IT IS A REALLY MULTI
FACETED. A POWER SOURCE YOU CAN
IT CAN ACTUALLY. OUR THE
GENERATION TO PRODUCE
ELECTRICITY IT CAN FUEL
VEHICLES IT CAN BE USED TO
STORE ELECTRICITY IT IT IT'S
VERY MULTI FACETED AND SO IF WE
CAN BEGIN TO PLAN FOR IT AND
DEPLOY IT AND SEND THE RIGHT
SIGNALS TO RESEARCHERS. TO
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPERS TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THEN IT COULD BE
A REALLY- OUR BENEFITS TO OUR
VARIOUS GOALS. SO WOULD THAT
BE- THE BILL AS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN VOTES AND NOT A YET
THE NEW BOAT AND WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS AS
YOU CAN TELL WE'RE MOVING
THROUGH THE FILE VERY QUICKLY
THIS MORNING. YOUR YOUR
CONVERSATIONS ON THE FLOOR
DISTRACTING TO THE AUTHORS THAT
ARE TRYING TO PRESENT THEIR
BILLS WOULD YOU PLEASE MIND
TAKING YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN.
CONTINUE ON OUR QUICK PACE OF
GETTING TO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS THIS MORNING THANK YOU
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE SP
EIGHTEEN IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM NINETY THREE. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
BASED I BECKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY I DON. TORONTO I
EGGMAN HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN ORDER I LAYERED
I LIVE IN. I LIVE MON. MCGUIRE
HI MELINDA'S HI MAN. I NEWMAN.
HI A SHOW OF BOTHHI PAM FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. HI ROCK. HI RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN HI AMBERG
FIVE WACO SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS.
AT KINS. GOD I. LIMONIUM HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE IT IN NINETY SEVEN SENATOR
HER TADO SENATE BILL FORTY.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FORTY BY SENATOR HER TADO
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
CENTER DOT ORG THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY RICE PRISON SP
FORTY TWO CALIFORNIA DREAM TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL ACT SB FORTY
ESTABLISHES A PRE MED PIPELINE
PROGRAM CREATING PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE FOUR
YEAR UNDERGRADUATE UNIVERSITIES
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOOLS
AND LOCAL HEALTH CENTERS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS WHO LIVE IN REGIONS
OF LIMITED HEALTH CARE
OPPORTUNITY. AND DREAM ABOUT
GOING TO MEDICAL SCHOOL. IN
pVALLEY THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
IMPERIAL VALLEY COMMUNITIES ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING THE PAINS
OF PROVIDER SHORTAGES AND A
LACK OF HEALTH CARE NETWORK
ADEQUACY. AND POOR ACCESS TO
TIMELY CARE WE MUST ADDRESS
THESE SHORTAGES NOW THE BILL
ESTABLISHES FOUR REGIONAL HUBS
OF HEALTHCARE OPPORTUNITY EACH
OF WHICH INCLUDE THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ONE FOR
YOUR UNDERGRADUATE INSTITUTION
ONE MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THREE
LOCAL COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
OF WHICH AT LEAST ONE MUST BE
LOCAL COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER.
AS BEFORE AIMS TO PRODUCE
PHYSICIANS WHO ONCE TRAINED
WOULD PROVIDE CARE IN SUCH
COMMUNITIES WHO COME FROM A
BACKGROUND THAT HELPS THEM
UNDERSTAND THE WAY OF LIFE. IN
THESE COMMUNITIES CRITICAL TO
PROVIDING. THE BEST CARE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. I WE HAVE EEN.
SOME OF OUR HIGHEST NUMBERS OF
INFECTIONS FATALITIES FROM COAL
BUT IN THESE. AREAS AND MAY
ALSO LIMIT THE DEVASTATION OF
THE FUTURE PANDEMIC THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM ENVISIONED SP FORTY
WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM OF YOUNG
STUDENTS. WHO COME FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
HAVE A UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO BEST SERVE THEM. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
D'AMATO SENATOR BARGES UNDER
DISCUSSION DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE EMERGED MR PRESIDENT I
WANT TO COMMEND THE SENATOR
FROM SANGER- I KNOW THIS. PILOT
PROGRAM WILL BE BENEFICIAL
ACROSS THE BOARD BUT IN
PARTICULAR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND JUST WANT TO
COMMEND HER FOR HER HARD WORK
IN THE SUBJECT MATTER. AND
HARDLY ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT THIS AS WELL. THANK
YOU SIR FOR JUST ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SENATE
BILL. FORTY ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE CENTER TARA LIKE TO CLOSE.
I CAN EXPRESS I RESPECT LAST
FOR ABOUT THANK YOU SIR SIX
PLEASE CALL ROLL. ALAN HI I
ARCHULETA. HI AT TEN. EIGHT I
BECKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI COURTESY
I DALLY. I DON. THERE ARE SO.
HI ADNAN HI GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WHERE SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES NO KAMMERER. I LAYERED I
LABOR. I LIVE MY OWN. MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN. HI NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN. BY A SHOW OF BOTH
HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
UMBERG HI WHAT CASKEY I WINNER
I WILL. I SIX A PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS. GOD I
GROVE I. LEMONS HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS NO. ONE KNOWS ONE
MAJOR PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL ITEM
ONE OR TWO ONE OH FOUR AND THEN
ONE OH SIX ONE OH TWO IS
SENATOR BECKER SENATE BILL.
SIXTY EIGHT. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ NFL SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BACKER AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY. THEY'RE BETTER.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
AT THREE SIXTY EIGHT ABOUT
REDUCING THE BARRIERS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO HELP
US ACHIEVE OUR CHRONICLES BY
LECTURE PRIME BUILDINGS AND
VEHICLES OFTENTIMES THEY FACE
HIGH COSTS AND LONG DELAYS
CONTRACTORS OFTEN HAVE LITTLE
EXPERIENCE AND FOLKS END UP
DOING COFFEE PANEL UPGRADES
THAT COULD BEEN AVOIDED THREE
SIXTY EIGHT IS ABOUT BETTER
INFORMATION AND BETTER
TECHNOLOGY. IT'LL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR OWNERS TO LECTURE
PART ENERGY USE IN THE
BUILDING'S FRONT CHARGES FOR
VEHICLES AND SUPPORTER STATE
GOALS OUR STRUCTURE WE ASK. FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR ANY
DISCUSS OR DEBATE ON FILE I
DON'T WANT TO. MEMBERS NEED TO.
OR DID. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS. BASE I BECKER FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A BETTER LIFE
FOR TESTING I DALLY. NO DOT HI-
OSEM HI AIKMAN I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WHERE SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN. HI
HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BY A SHOW
OF VOGUE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER.
HI STERN HI AMBERG HI BY CAL
SKI. FIVE WINNER I WILL. I.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS PORGES. GROVE
LIMONIUM. HIGHS THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS ONE MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS
ARE MOVING ON TO FIGHT ON ONE
OH FOUR CENTRE ALAN SENATE BILL.
EIGHTY THREE. MEMBERS RIGHT
TAKE A PILOT MODEL SIX AFTER
THIS ONE OF FOUR IS CENTER
ALLEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALAN AND ACTUALLY TO
COASTAL SERVER RESOURCES. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
SEALEVEL RISE THREATENS TO
ERODE CLIFFS AND FLOOD HOMES
ALONG THE ENTIRETY OF THE SET
OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST. FROM
NORTH TO SOUTH R. ELLIE-
ESTIMATES AROUND EIGHT TO TEN
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
EXISTING PROPERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. IS LIKELY TO BE
UNDER WATER BY TWENTY FIFTY AND
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION IN PROPERTY COULD BE AT
RISK OF FLOODING BY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED BY. TWENTY ONE HUNDRED.
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY CAUSING A
POLITICAL AND FINANCIAL CRISIS
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY
HAVE LIMITED BUDGETS- BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT
THEIR CITY GOVERNMENTS TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE. TO PROTECT
THEIR HOMES AND THEY'RE NOW
SPENDING MORE AND MORE MONEY.
ON MITIGATION. SO IN AREAS
ALREADY EXPERIENCING FLOODING
BUYING OUT LOCAL RESIDENTS AND
RELOCATING THEM HAS BEEN VERY
CONTROVERSIAL IN SOME
INSTANCES. COST PROHIBITIVE. OF
COURSE BUILDING SEA WALLS IS
NOT JUST EXPENSIVE AS THE
ANALYST- AS THE INOTES FOR NOW
SAYS YOU CAN CHECK OUT POINTS
OUT IF IT COMES WITH SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCES AND
OF COURSE. IT'S A IT'S A- TO
REALLY- IMPOSSIBLE FIGHT TO WIN
AGAINST THE C. SO THESE ARE
SOME TOUGH CHOICES- BUT WE'RE-
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL IS PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH AN INNOVATIVE
FINANCING OPTION TO ALLEVIATE
THE REST OF C. LEVEL RISE WHILE
PROTECTING BOTH PROPERTY OWNERS
AND TAXPAYERS. IT BASICALLY
STOP WHICH IS A REVOLVING LOAN
FUND FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
BUY PROPERTIES THAT WILL BE
THREATENED IN A DECADE OR TWO.
AND THEN IT ALLOWS THE OWNERS.
TO SELL WHILE THE HOUSE IS
STILL HAS VALUE AND THEN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CAN THEN RENT
OUT THE PROPERTY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT VERY VIABLE PROPERTIES
OFTEN TIMES IT CAN BE RENTED AT
A VERY HIGH AND- AMOUNT. AND
THE IDEA IS THAT THAT WILL THEN
REPAY THE LOAN AND POTENTIALLY
EVEN EARN REVENUE OVER TIME.
AND THEN WHEN THE RISK. OF
FLOODING FROM RISING SEA LEVELS
GETS TO AND- AND UNBEARABLE
POINT THE HOUSE COULD BE
DEMOLISHED OR RELOCATED WITHOUT
LOCAL RESIDENTS. OR TAXPAYERS
BEARING THE COST. YOU THAT IF
WE ACT NOW USER THE TIME WE
HAVE A- MANY CO. COMMUNITIES
ARE RISK HOMEOWNERS AND
TAXPAYERS CAN REMAIN WHOLE. WE
CAN ACTUALLY BREAK EVEN WITH
THIS. NOT ILL HELP TO ALLEVIATE
THIS ENORMOUS CHALLENGE AT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FACE. IT'S
ENTIRELY PERMISSIVE TOOL. AS I
SAY WE WANT THIS TO BALANCE OUT
FINANCIALLY FOR THE STATE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. IT'S
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AS A-
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM ONE OF FOUR SENATE
BILL EIGHTY THREE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS BAIT. BECKER HI FOR JUST
HI BRADFORD HI BYRON HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. NO DODD. HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
HI JONES FIVE KM LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA HI LYNN MON.
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. MAN
FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. I COULD
SHOW BOTH HI PAN HI HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI ROB. HI RUBIO. FIVE
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER ALL
RIGHT HI WHAT KIND OF SPEED I
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS.
BAIT LIMONIUM. MELINDA'S NOW.
HIGHS THIRTY FIVE KNOWS TO
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
SIX WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
ONE NINETEEN ONE TWENTY SIX
FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX IS SENATOR
HER TADO. ON A SENATE BILL ONE
OH EIGHT SENATOR APPEARS TO BE
READY THE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ONE OH EIGHT
BY SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO FOOD ACCESS. TODAY
I RISE ON THE RIGHTS SHOULD BE
SENATE BILL ONE OF OUR FINAL
ITEM ONE OF SIX. IS THAT
CORRECT FOR ONE OF SIX IN A
BILL ONE WEEK. I'M SORRY MR I
BET. CENTER TITLE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SP ONE ZERO EIGHT THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO FOOD ACT.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE ON THE VERGE
OF A FOOD CRISIS A THIRD. OF
GLOBAL FOR A FOOD PRODUCTION IS
AT RISK DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
ALONE. ENERGY MAKES UP 19% OF
THE AMERICAN FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN
WITH INCREASING PRICES AND
ENERGY WE ARE SEEING FOOD COSTS
ALSO INCREASE. IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE FACING A DROUGHT THAT IS
ALREADY PUTTING FOOD OUT OF
PRODUCTION. JUST LIKE THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE ARE
UNPREPARED FOR A FOOD CRISIS.
WE NEED FOOD RESILIENCE AND
ADAPTIVE CAPACITY BECAUSE FOOD
IS HEALTH AND FOOD IS LIFE.
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY FEEDS THE
STATE WE FEED THE WORLD. THIS
IS AS IMPORTANT TODAY AS IT
WILL E TOMORROW. AS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION GROWS
AS A CLIMATE GETS WARMER AND AS
LAND USAGE CHANGES OUR ABILITY
TO KEEP PACE AND FEED THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE WILL BE
CHALLENGED WE MUST PREPARE FOR
THESE CHALLENGES AND THAT IS
WHY IT AND THAT IS WHY I AM
INTRODUCING SB ONE ZERO EIGHT.
AS B. ONE ZERO EIGHT REQUIRES
STATE AGENCIES TO CONSIDER THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO FOOD AS THEY
CREATE AMEND OR ADOPT
REGULATIONS BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES A REPORT ON THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE STATUS OF
FOOD FOOD PRODUCTION AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE. S. B. ONE ZERO
EIGHT TO CLOSE IT BE
ESTABLISHED POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA THAT EVERY HUMAN
BEING HAS A RIGHT TO ACCESS
SUFFICIENT HEALTHY AND
AFFORDABLE FOOD WE MUST MAKE
SURE THE PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
ARE FED NOW AND IN THE FUTURE.
THIS BILL WORKS TOWARDS THAT
END. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER TARA MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM ONE OH SIX SENATE BILL ONE
OH EIGHT SENATOR GROWTH YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL ONE AWAIT AND I
APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUES THIS
YEAR'S KERN COUNTY. WITH ME SHE
ALSO IS THE- REPRESENTATIVE
THAT SHARES PART OF FRESNO
COUNTY. FRESNO WHICH IS NUMBER
ONE IN FOOD PRODUCTION IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO IS CELEBRATING BUT HE
JUST TOOK THAT FROM KERN COUNTY
JUST LAST YEAR AND I THINK THAT
SECRETARY ROSS MAY HAVE MADE A-
SLIGHT ERROR. AT CURRENT COUNTY
IS NUMBER TWO IN FOOD
PRODUCTION IN TH ENTIRE WORLD.
WE ALSO PRODUCE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER HUNDRED
COMMODITIES. THAT WE PRODUCE
99% AT. SO IF YOU THINK YOU CAN
CUT OFF WATER AND YOU CAN- STOP
US FROM GROWING FOOD IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT AND- THAT'S A BIG MISTAKE
BECAUSE. THERE'S NOT ANY OTHER
PLACE IN THE WORLD. THERE NOT
ANY OTHER IN THE WORLD THA HAS
THE FOOD PRODUCTION THAT WE
HAVE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY- AND
THAT'S NOT THE STATE COLLEAGUES
THAT'S THE WORLD YOUR
CONSTITUENTS EAT THEM THE
NATION'S CONSTITUENTS EAT OUR
FOOD. AND IN THE WORLD IT ALSO
BENEFITS FROM THIS FOOD SUPPLY-
I APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUES FOR AT
LEAST GETTING THIS STARTED I
APPLAUD HER FOR MAKING SURE
THIS BILL GETS OUT. BECAUSE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE COLLEAGUES
THAT FOOD INSECURITY- DOESN'T
HAPPEN ON OUR WATCH AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE PRODUCE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO PRODUCE
FOOD FOR OUR NATION AND OUR
WORLD IT'S SIGNIFICANT. AND I
WOULD ASK FOR A NINE VOTE.
THANK YOU GENERATED FROM KERN
COUNTY WITH THE GENTLEMAN FROM
FRESNO LIKED TO BE RECOGNIZED
FOR REBUTTAL. GERMAN FROM
FRESNO PAT. OKAY I'LL PASS
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FROM FRESNO
SENATORS ANY OTHERS WISHING TO
RECOGNIZE ON FILE ITEM ONE OF
SIX SENATE BILL ONE OH WAIT FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ANY OTHER
COUNTIES WANT TO CLAIM NUMBER
ONE AND- PRODUCTIVITY IN THE
WORLD. ARE YOU SAYING NINE
CENTER TOTAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I HAVE THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING BOTH COUNTY SO I
WILL NOT COMMENT ON- DO YOU
KNOW WHICH ONE PRODUCES THE
MOST AMOUNT OF FOOD BUT I WILL
SAY THAT THEY BOTH. ARE EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE FOOD- MAKING
SURE THAT THE WORLD IS FOOD
SECURE AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
pOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR TADO
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
EIGHT HI BECKER. HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A- HI
COURTESY I DALLY. DODD FIVE
TORONTO HI EGGMAN. HI GLAZER.
HI CAN DOLLARS HIGH GROWTH BY
HERZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO KAMMERER I LAYERED
I LABOR HI LYNN MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
NUMBER HI WHAT KIND OF SKI. HI
WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS.
DALLY. THE MON. MELINDA'S HIGHS
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN FOLLOWED
BY ONE TWENTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN IS AN ARCH ALETTA
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN.
CENTER ARCHULETA IS READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREWORKS MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. THE MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL TWO SEVEN SEVEN. FOR TOO
LONG OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
PLAGUED BY THE PERSISTENT BOOMS
AND BANGS OF ILLEGAL AMATEUR
FIREWORKS IN THIS PLACE LOCAL
FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN KEPT FROM
OTHER DUTIES AS WELL AS BUSY
RESPONDING TO RESIDENTS
COMPLAINTS. ABOUT THESE ILLEGAL
AERIAL DISPLAYS AND CELEBRATE
TORY EXPLOSIVE NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT THE RELENTLESS DISRUPTION
TO OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DISRUPTIVE
AND UNWELCOME. DESPITE AN
INCREASE IN FOURTH IN EFFORTS
TO INCREASE PUBLIC EDUCATION
USE OF ADMINISTRATIVE FINES AND
DEPLOYING DEDICATED LEGAL.
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS IN PATROLS
THE VOLUME OF ILLEGAL AERIAL
ITEMS AND LOUD EXPLOSIVE
REMAIN. AT UNACCEPTABLE LEVELS.
ON TOP OF ALL THIS AFTER
SUCCESSFULLY FINDING AND
CONFISCATING ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
LOCAL BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
MUST PAY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
HAVE THEM SHIPPED OUT OF STATE
AND DISPOSED OF PROPERLY EVEN
WHEN WE WIN IT SEEMS WE'RE
STILL LOSING. SO WITH THESE
REASONS I WILL SAY THAT I HAVE.
NO OPPOSITION RECEIVED NO VOTES
IN FOR USER RESPECTFULLY FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOUS IN
ARCHULETA MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM ONE NINETEEN CENTER
BURGESS. MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN.
I HAVE THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING- FRESNO AND THE-
JOINING US ANYONE KEEN RIVER.
OF FIREWORKS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FIRES
IN ONLY A- A NUMBER OF YEARS
BACK IT WAS CALLED THE WORST
FIRE IN OUR REGION IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS- BECAUSE OF THESE
ACTIVITIES. AND IN THE ILLEGAL
STORING OF THESE OLDER PRODUCTS
SO ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT TWO SEVEN
SEVEN THANK. YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ITEM FORWARD. THANK YOU
SIR BORJA ANY OTHER DISCUSS OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN. IN ARCHULETA WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I. VOTE EXCELLENT CLOSE MEMBERS
THIS QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FIGHT ON. ONE
TWENTY SIX. WHICH IS SENATOR
LEYVA ON A SENATE BILL. THREE
OH NINE. SENATOR LEYVA IS READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE OH NINE BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACT RELATED TO SCHOOL
FINANCE. SENER LEVENT THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE FOR ME
TO PRESENT SP THREE OH NINE A
COLLEGE ACCESS FOR ALL ACT. AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I FIRMLY BELIEVE IN
EQUITY AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF THEIR BACKGROUND
OR CIRCUMSTANCES ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE
THAT ONLY HALF OF GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA MEET THE COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS TO ATTEND A U. C.
OR YOU SEE A FEW. AND EVEN
FEWER SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED HOMELESS ENGLISH
LEARNER AND FOSTER STUDENTS
MEET THESE FRUIT REQUISITES.
THREE THROUGH NINE WILL FINALLY
HELP TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
FIRST SP THREE OH NINE SUBJECT
TO APPROPRIATION ESTABLISHES A
GRANT PROGRAM THAT FUNDS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ACCESS GRANTS. TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
WITHIN EIGHT THROUGH G.
COMPLETION RATE OF LESS THAN
45% IN ORDER TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO A THREE G. COURSES. AND ALSO
FUNDS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
SUCCESS PRINCE FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT HAVE
INCORPORATED A THROUGH G.
COURSES. HAVE BEEN REQUIREMENTS
INTO THEIR LOCAL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS BUT EIGHT THREE G.
REQUIREMENT COMPLETION RATE
REMAINS BELOW 80% OVER ALL.
SECOND OF THREE THREE OH NINE
STRENGTHENS NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS AND PARENTS BEGINNING
IN EIGHTH GRADE KNOW THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENTS WHETHER THEY ALIGN
TO THEIR LOCAL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS AND OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS EIGHT THREE G.
COMPLETION RATE. AS WELL AS THE
RATES OF OTHER SCHOOLS WITHIN
THE L. EA FINALLY SP THREE OH
NINE ENSURES THAT ALL HIGHSCHOOL STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
TAKE THE COURSE IS REQUIRED TO
ATTEND A UC OR CSU IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. WHAT AID THAT WHETHER
THEY ATTEND A TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL A CHARTER SCHOOL
OR SCHOOL OPERATED. BY THE
COUNTY SUCH AS A JUVENILE CORK
CENTER. MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
LEYVA MEMBER DISCUSS OR TO
SENATOR CHARLES. THANK YOU MR
AND- THANK YOU FOR THE EFFORT
TO SPEAK HI RISE IN SUPPORT OF
S. THREE NINE AS THE G. OF THE
IN EMPIRE CAUCUS. THIS GRAND
PER OVER MATCHING TO LOCAL EDGY
TO CONDITIONALLY JUST TO SERVE
THERE'S TO. ESPECIALLY THOSE
THIS BACK. WHO TYPICALLY HAVE A
MUCH LOWER RATE OF COMPLETING
THESE ADDITIONAL COURSES. FOR
THESE REASONS SP THREE ZERO
NINE IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
INLAND EMPIRE POCKETS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR IF THE BILL PASSES.
ON THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO JOIN ME IN VOTING HI. THANK
YOU SENATOR JOE BOWEN ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR DISCUSSION ON
SENATE BILL THREE OH NINE.
SENIOR LEVEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU TO SEND A
TOWBOAT WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE CALL AS A CO AUTHOR
IF THE BILL GETS ALL FOUR
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR NINE. I THINK IS BEST EIGHT
PLEASE THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. BAIT
BACKER HI PORGES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T I COURTESY. HI
DALLY. DOT FIVE THERE ARE SO HI
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE MY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. FIVE JONES NO KAMMERER I
LAYERED I LIVE IN FIVE THE MON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW BOTH
HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER HI STERN
ALL RIGHT HI AMBERG HI WHITE
HOUSE E. FIVE WINNER. I WILL
LOOK. PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. AT KINS. BABIES.
PORGES DALLY. GROVE NO. LIMON
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN I. WILKE NO.
MEMBERS WANNA GO ONE MORE TIME
TO THE ROLE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BAIT.
FOR JUST. DALLY LIMONIUM.
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU HIGHS
THIRTY ONE KNOWS THREE MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FIGHT ON ONE THIRTY FOLLOWED
BY FILE AND I'M FORTY EIGHT
FILE IN ONE THIRTY FOLLOWED BY
FILING A MORE FORTY EIGHT AT
ONE THIRTY IS SENATOR SKINNER
ON SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER NATURALLY NEED
TO FOSTER YOUTH. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
WILL HELP US PLACE CHILDREN
WITH THEIR FAMILIES WHERE THEY
WILL DO BETTER IT WAS ON
CONSENT CALENDAR IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I ASKED FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SENATE BILL. THREE FIFTY FOUR.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION THIS
MEASURE QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NO OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER NOW MEMBERS
MOVING BACK TO FILE FORTY
EIGHT. SENATOR EDMUND. ON. SP
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY BY SENATOR
ADMIN AN ACT RELATING TO END OF
LIFE. CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY 2% SP
THREE EIGHTY A BILL THAT WILL
MAKE SOME REVISIONS TO THE END
OF LIFE OPTIONS ACT THAT WE
AUTHORED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN IT
WENT INTO EFFECT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. SINCE THAT BILL PASSED
WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS AND CONTINUE TO TRACK
THE DATA THAT WE RECEIVE ON HOW
THAT OPTION IS GOING IT'S GOING
VERY WELL OVER TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAD BEEN ABLE TO-
PEACEFULLY- AND THEIR LIVES
WHEN THEY HAVE A TERMINAL
ILLNESS FROM WHICH NO CURE IS
EXPECTED AND THAT IS VERIFIED
BY. TWO PHYSICIANS- SO AT THIS
POINT WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVED
THE SUNSET FOR THIS WE ARE
GOING TO REDUCE THE MANDATORY
WAITING PERIOD FROM FIFTEEN
DAYS TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET RID OF THAT
FINAL FOURTH ATTESTATION- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE THIS HAS- CMA IS. AND
OPPOSED HOSPITALS ARE ON OPPO-
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY. FOR
YOUR VOTE ON THIS BILL TO HELP.
THOSE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
TERMINALLY ILL. THANK YOU
CENTER ADMIN MEMBERS THIS IS A
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SP THREE
EIGHTY IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. IN DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING NONE THE CENTER I
MEAN I'M I'M SORRY WE DO HAVE
A- SPINNERBAITS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT JUST A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR ON THE SECOND SET OF
DATE OF REVISION AND REMOVAL OF
THAT SINCE THAT SEEM TO BE A
CRITICAL ISSUE WHEN THE BILL
WAS PASSED THAT WE WOULD HAVE.
THE OUR INFORMATION FROM THEIR
STUDIES THE ATTESTATIONS FILLED
OUT THE SUNSET REVIEW CAN DEAL
WITH THE CONTINUATION OF THE
BILL WHEN IT WAS MEETING AT
FIVE IT'S MOST NOBLE PURPOSE SO
IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN NOW WHY
WE'RE REMOVING THAT SUNSET
DATE. THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
THANK YOU SERIGNE ARE YOU
WILLING TO TAKE A QUESTION. OF
COURSE THANK GOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR-
WHEN WE PASSED IT YES WE SAID
WE WOULD HAVE HEARINGS AND WE
HAVE CONTINUED TO HAVE THOSE
DATA WILL CONTINUE TO BE
COLLECTED AND REPORTED EVERY
YEAR- THAT THIS DOES NOT STOP
THE DATA COLLECTION THAT GOES
TO THAT DEPARTMENT. AND SO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT TO
REVIEW IF THERE'S A PROBLEM
THAT ARISES WE CAN CERTAINLY
MAKE SOME CORRECTIONS BUT AT
THIS POINT WE DIDN'T THINK IT
WAS NECESSARY TO CONTINUE TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE. FOR
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN IN EFFECT
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN AND BEEN
IN EFFECT AND IN AROUND THE
WORLD FOR WELL OVER. TWENTY
YEARS AT THIS POINT. THANK YOU
SIR I MEAN ANY. MEN WILL WISH
BE RECOGNIZED FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. INTERVENTION WE RECEIVE
THE ARE CLOSE TO YOU CERTAINLY
THINK VERY MUCH MR. THANK YOU
CENTER ADMIN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BASE. THIS
IS FAITH. NO BACKER. FIVE
PORGES NO BRADFORD HI BY ADAM
HI COURTESY. DALLY NO DODD. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI PLEASE SIR
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI LISTEN. HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LIVE IN I LIVE ALONE.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A SHOW
VOGUE. PAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN HI AMBER I LIKE HOW SKI
HI WINNER. HI WELK NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
CORTELLI. WITH SO. LEMON THAT
SHOW BOTH. FOURTEEN TINO. SIZE
TWENTY SIX NOS EIGHT MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT AND THEN ONE FORTY
TWO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE
THE SENATOR CABALLERO ON SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY ONE CENTER
COPIER WAS READY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. AT ABOUT SEVENTY
ONE BY SENATOR KABBADI AUTO AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY CENTER
COPIER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B.
THREE SEVENTY ONE WHICHIS
ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE
FRAMEWORK TO BUILD UPON
EXISTING DATA EXCHANGE EFFORTS
IN THE STATE FOR A MORE ROBUST
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE.
THIS WILL ALLOW HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS TO ACCESS PATIENT
MEDICAL RECORDS AND INFORMATION
IN A SAFE SECURE AND TIMELY
MANNER MANY SMALL RURAL AND
SAFETY NET PRACTICES LACK THE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND FUNDING
TO ACCESS THE SYSTEMS- SP THREE
SEVENTY ONE ADDRESSES NOT ONLY
THE VALUE OF THE INTERCONNECTED
BODY BUT ALSO MEETS THE NEEDS
OF PHYSICIAN PRACTICES WHERE
THEY ARE ON THE TECHNOLOGY
SPECTRUM. AND HELPS TO BRING IT
EQUITY TO THE SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SENATOR CAMARO
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY THREE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE AND
ONE THIRTY THREE SEEING NO
OBJECTION. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES. NEXUS
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
SENATOR LAYERED ON SP THREE
NINETY. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY BY
SENATOR LAYERED AND ACTUALLY
INTO UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
SENATOR LARGER RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT EARLIER IN
THIS FLOOR SESSION WE DISCUSSED
THE STATE AUDITOR'S AUDIT OF
THE E. D. D. MELTDOWN ON THE
PROBLEMS WE'VE ALL FACED ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS IS IN THE
GREAT RECESSION AND WITH THIS
INCIDENT THERE WAS NO PLANNING
FOR HOW TO GO. IN THE EVENT OF
A MAJOR RECESSION THE ONE OF
THE LARGE OF RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE AUDITOR IS THAT THERE
BE A RECESSION PLANNED SO THAT
WE ARE READY TO GO RIGHT INTO A
RESPONSE MODE WHENEVER THIS
HAPPENS AGAIN THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS THAT RECOMMENDATION
IT'S SUPPORTED BY BOTH BUSINESS
AND LABOR ENJOYS BIPARTISAN CO
AUTHORS AND IT'S RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES IN THE PROCESS I ASKED
FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED MEMBERS ON
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WE HAVE
SENATOR NIELSEN. FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR GROWTH. SPREAD THE LADY
THE THIS IS UTTERLY COMMON
SENSE AND THAT NOT. A FACTOR.
IN THE PLAN. AND PREPARATION.
AND FOR THE OF THE DECK. IS
INCOMPETENCE. IN FACT ALMOST
THIS. FOR THE THAT THAT AGENCY
IS SUPPOSED TO BE OF ASSISTANCE
TO. THIS INDEED WAS ONE OF THE
KEY SEVERAL ELEMENTS OF
STRUCTURAL CHANGE PROPOSED BY.
THE AUTHOR AND WE NEED TO
INCORPORATE IN STATUTE THIS
YEAR EVERY ONE OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS AGENCY
CANNOT BE FIXED BY TINKERING
AROUND THE EDGES DRASTIC
CHANGES REQUIREDTHIS IS ONE OF
THOSE KEY AND FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES THAT IS GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO ENSURE THAT
UNEMPLOYED. CALIFORNIANS IN THE
FUTURE. ARE NOT SO DEVASTATED
BY THE INCOMPETENCE OF THE
STATE AGENCY. THANK YOU SIR AND
CENTER GROVE YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FRIEND
BRINGING FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IN HELPING US WITH
SOLVING THE EDT PROBLEM AND-
FOLLOWING SOME OF THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS TO COLLEGE
IS JUST A COMMON SENSE BILL WE
NEED TO BE READY FOR THE NEXT
DISASTER AND THEN AGAIN WE ALL
TOOK THOSE PHONE CALLS THERE'S
A MILLION PERCENT BACKLOG.
PEOPLE THAT DESERVE THOSE
BENEFITS THAT HAD NO CHOICE OF
THEIR OWN- THEY WERE JUST TOLD
THEIR JOB WAS AN ESSENTIAL AND
THEY WEREN'T ALLOWED TO GO TO
WORK THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE-
BE ABLE TO GET THEIR BENEFITS
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT GOOD
THINGS ARE HAPPENING AT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WITH DIRECTOR SIGNS
BEING APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. SHE'S A
PROBLEM SOLVER BILLS LIKE SB
THIRTY NINE IT JUST GOT OFF THE
FLOOR AND MY COLLEAGUES STILL
AN SP THREE NINETY- WHICH WILL
FOLD INTO SOMETHING WONDERFUL
TO FIX THE ISSUES AT THE EDT SO
I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE
SENATOR MAN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS COMMON SENSE BILL HI LIKE
MANY OF YOU MY DISTRICT OFFICE
HAS BEEN INUNDATED WITH EDT
CLAIMS AND WE'VE BEEN SPENDING
ALL OF OUR TIME TRYING TO GET-
UNFORTUNATELY LAID OFF-
CONSTITUENTS THEIR HARD EARNED
AND WELL DESERVED BENEFITS- IS
THIS HORRIFIC THE FAILURES ARE
WELL DOCUMENTED. AND IT SHOULD
NOT BE UP TO LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICT OFFICES TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE THERE ET DE OUGHT TO TRY
TO GET SOMEONE ON THE PHONE AND
WE ALL KNOW WHAT A PROBLEM THIS
IS- AND SO- I APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL WE NEED
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM WHAT WE
SAW OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF CAN NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN
THIS THIS WAS VERY FORESEEABLE
THE RISE IN CLAIMS. AND I-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU CENTER MANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED UNDER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNISED.
CENTRE LAYERED WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR COMMENTS AND I ASKED
FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED CENTERS THIS QUALIFIES.
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OF ACTION TO USING.
ROLE CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NO OBJECT. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS.
MAJOR MEMBERS OF ON TO FILE AND
ONE FORTY TWO. FOLLOWED BY A
FORTY SIX FOR A FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY TWO IS SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN. SENATOR HUESO. IT IS
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ AT
THE FOUR SIXTEEN BY SENATOR WAY
SO AN ACT RELATING TO
CORRECTIONS. CENTER WE STILL.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS.
I'M VERY PROUD TO PRESENT THE.
AS FOUR SIXTEEN THE
INCARCERATED STUDENTS BILL OF
RIGHTS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST BOLD
VULNERABLE COLLEGE POPULATIONS
AND ULTIMATELY IMPLEMENT
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS IN THE
PENAL CODE I GUESS THERE IS NO.
A DEBATE THAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO
COME OUT OF OUR PRISON SYSTEM
IMPROVED CORRECTED AND- IN MANY
CASES BETTER EDUCATED SO THEY
DON'T RECIDIVISTS. SO THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE INCARCERATED
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO FACE TO
FACE COLLEGE INSTRUCTION ONLY
PROVIDED Y QUALIFIED
REGIONALLY ACCREDITED NONPROFIT
HIGHER EDUCATION PROVIDERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION GRANT AND
CONSERVE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. ACCESS TO PELL
GRANTS AND THIS NEW ELIGIBILITY
HAS ALREADY GREATLY INCREASE
COLLEGE OUTREACH THROUGH CDC
ARE. PARTICULARLY FROM FOR
PROFIT SEEKING TO ROLL STUDENTS.
IT IS IN THEIR PROGRAM AS
BEFORE SIXTEEN WILL PROHIBIT
CDC ARE FROM REPLACING PUBLIC
BET NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WITH ONLY PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS AS
HAPPENED IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY IT'S REALLY WITHIN OUR
BEST INTEREST TO PROMOTE HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND IMPROVE ACCESS
TO PURPOSEFUL EDUCATION WITHIN
OUR PRISONS I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON SENATE
BILL FOUR SIXTEEN. SEEING NO
OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SIX SENATOR GONZALES.
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY TWO
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. THIRTEEN
DOLLARS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SP FOUR FIFTY TWO WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE AFFAIRS
AGENCY TO SERVE IN A SISTER
STATE SERVERS IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES. WELL THERE ARE A
HANDFUL OF LOCAL PROGRAMS
OFFERING SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CALIFORNIA
LACKS A CENTRALIZED VOICE IN
HELPING US MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE LARGE IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
POPULATION IN OUR STATE AS
BEFORE FIVE TO PROVIDE THE
PROACTIVE SOLUTION BY
ESTABLISHING AN OFFICE THAT
WILL BE DEDICATED TO OFFERING
DIRECT SERVICES. INCREASING
COMMUNICATION AND ADDRESSING
THE RAPID STATE AND FEDERAL
POLICY CHANGES THAT IMPACT OUR
FELLOW IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
CALIFORNIANS I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU DURING
HIS OFFICE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
AND ONE FORTY SIX SENATE BILL.
FOUR FIFTY TO ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS. EIGHT NO BACKER I PORCHES
NO BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
COURTESY. HI DALLY NO DOG. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
CONDOLENCES HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES. NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED HI LISA I LIVE MON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
I. NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A
TROVE OF. HI PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO. I
SCANNER. STERN FIVE NUMBER I Y.
CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WILL NO
PLEASE CALL THE OPPOSITE
MEMBERS. ATKINS GROVE. NO
LIMONIUM SKINNER. I. HIGHS
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS I'M SORRY
EYES THIRTY. KNOWS EIGHT MAJOR
PASSES LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE WE ARE JOINED THIS
MORNING BUYERS TEAM FORMER
COLLEAGUE AND CURRENT LA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL. THANK YOU SINNERS
GOOD MORNING SENATOR MITCHELL
GOOD TO SEE YOU- MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA SKIP FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
TWO WERE MOVING ON TO FALL AND
ONE FIFTY THREE SENATE BILL
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN SENATOR
WIENER'S SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU FOR MAKING ME COMPETE
WITH SENATOR MITCHELL IS ALWAYS
A- ALWAYS A BATTLE YOU'RE GONNA
LOSE- WELCOME BACK SUPERVISOR-
OUR COLLEAGUES ARRIVED TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN THE HOUSING DATA
ACT THIS IS. A VERY GOOD GOOD
GOVERNMENT DATA COLLECTION
BILL- CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED A
NUMBER OF STATE HOUSING LAWS IN
RECENT YEARS TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- DATA COLLECTION
ON THE IMPLEMENTATIONS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE LAWS.
HAS BEEN SPOTTY AT BEST-IN
ORDER FOR US TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE DOING WITH
HOUSING HEALTH AFFECTED THESE
LAWS ARE WHETHER CHANGES NEED
TO BE MADE AT CETERA- WE NEED
TO HAVE MUCH MORE CONSISTENT
AND METHODICAL- DATA COLLECTION
SP FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN. IT
BUILDS ON- CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- CITIES ALREADY
MAKE I'M YOU'LL DATA REPORTS TO
THE STATE AND THIS WILL SIMPLY
EXPAND WHAT THEY REPORT ON-
AGAIN DATA COLLECTION IS. THE
COLLECTION IS CRITICAL TO
ACCOUNT OF. TRANSPARENCY THIS
IS GOOD GUY MEASURE I RESPECT
ASK. THANK YOU CENTER WINNER
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISK OR
DEBATE ON FILE I ONE FIFTY
THREE SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
EIGHT BACKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG HI WAY SO. HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LIVE IN. HI LYNN MON.
THE CHOIR HI MELINDA'S FIVE MEN.
HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH. I REVIEW HI SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT HI
WHAT KIND OF SKI. FIVE WINNER I
WELL I. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS FACE.
DALLY THE MON. NIELSEN HI.
HIGHS THIRTY SIX KNOWS ZERO
MAJOR PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY FIVE WHICH WILL BE FILED
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
NINE. ON ONE SIXTY FIVE ITS
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR
SENATOR LAYERED. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR LAYERED
AND ACTS RELATING TO CANNABIS.
A WOMAN. THE SENATOR LAYERED I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AS
INTERLAYER SIMILAR EXCUSE ME
ONE SECOND. LET. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THERE'S A LOT OF
CHATTER ON THE FLOOR IF WE
COULD PLEASE SHOW DEFERENCE TO
THE- AUTHORS THAT ARE
PRESENTING I'D APPRECIATE IT I
THINK WE'D ALL APPRECIATE IT
SENT EARLIER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SP FIVE FORTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TO ESTABLISH TESTING
STANDARDS. TO BE USED BY ALL
TESTING LABORATORIES BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I ASKED
FOR MY PHONE. EXCELLENT OPEN
SOONER OR LATER IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MEMBERS
THIS. MAJOR QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE AND ONE SIXTY NINE.
SENATOR CALERO SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT. SHE'S GOING TO
PASS THE ON FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY CENTER TADO SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY NINE. SINNER TITLE
IS READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER. THANK YOU I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SP FIVE
FIVE NINE THE STATE WATER
RESILIENCY ACT. AS I SAID
BEFORE WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF A
GLOBAL FOOD CRISIS. AND WE ARE
ALSO NOW. ON THE VERGE AN ENTRY
IN A WATER CRISIS THAT REQUIRES
IMMEDIATE ACTION ONE THAT COULD
FIND YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND MINE
THE ONLY SEARCHING FOR FOOD BUT
ALSO SEARCHING FOR WATER. AS
PRICES GO UP IN RESPONSE TO THE
DECREASED WATER ACCESS AN
INCREASED COST IN GETTING FOOD
WORKS GOING FROM FARMS TO
GROCERY STORES AND EVENTUALLY.
OUR DINNER TABLES SP FIVE FIVE
NINE CAN HELP PREVENT THIS.
LAST SESSION I INTRODUCED A
BILL OF THE SAME NUMBER THE
REQUESTED FUNDING TO RESTORE
THE CARRYING CAPACITYOF THE
FRANK KERN CANAL. THAT BILL WAS
ULTIMATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR BUT STARTED A LARGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW AND
WHERE WE SHOULD BE SPENDING
MONEY WHEN WE HAVE IT. TO
REPAIR MUCH NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN BETTER
PREPARE US FOR OUR WATER NEEDS
AND DROUGHT AND NON DROUGHT
YEARS. IN RECENT DECADES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE WISE
DECISIONS TO INVEST IN
REPAIRING OUR CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. INCLUDING IN
THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
PREPARATION OF OVER ONE BILLION
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE NEW
BAY BRIDGE BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND. THOUGH
THE BRIDGE WAS DELAYED OPENING
AND CAUSE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
THAN ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED TO
COST THE STATE MOVED FORWARD
WITH THE PROJECT BECAUSE AS ONE
OF THE MOST HEAVILY TRAVELED
BRIDGES IN OUR STATE. IT WAS
NECESSARY TO REPAIR AND
PROVIDED A NET BENEFIT FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE TO DO SO. AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FAILING WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS NO LESS
IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE AND TO
ALL OF US THAT LIVE HERE. WE
GROW CROPS THAT FEED THE WORLD.
BUT THIS IS NOT JUST FOR
AGRICULTURE. THIS WATER IS USED
BY RESIDENTS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND URBAN USERS AMAZON
JEALOUS. APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
ONE MILLION OF THEM. SOME OF
WHOM LIVE IN OUR STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THIS
WATER ALSO PROTECTS THE LARGEST
REMAINING WETLAND COMPLEX IN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES.
WHICH IS HOME TO OVER ONE
MILLION MIGRATING BIRDS AND IS
RECOGNIZED AS A WETLAND OF
INTERNATIONAL IMPORTANCE.
HOWEVER WITH THAT BEING SAID.
LET'S NOT DISCOUNT THE IMPACT
THE SLEEVES LEGISLATION WILL
HAVE ON OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY EITHER. FARMING
CONTRIBUTES ABOUT FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
EVERY YEAR AND THAT'S WITHOUT
ACCOUNTING FOR ECONOMIC IMPACT
ON FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES ALL
OVER THE STATE. IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE RECOGNIZED OUR STRATEGIC
ADVANTAGES IN CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES AND HAVE ACTED TO
ENSURE THE STAY STRONG. SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALLOCATED ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION STRUCTURE
THOSE PRODUCTION STAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLIONDOLLARS A
YEAR AND I SUPPORT IT WE NEED
THOSE JOBS IN OUR STATE. BUT
JUST LIKE HOLLYWOOD
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY IS A WORLD LEADER.
THREE OF THE FOUR LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCING COUNTIES
IN THE UNITED STATES ARE IN MY
SENATE DISTRICT. WE NEED THE
JOBS THAT THESE THAT THIS
INDUSTRY SUPPORTS TO. PERHAPS
MORE IMPORTANTLY CALIFORNIA
NEEDS THE FOOD BUT THIS
INDUSTRY PRODUCES. BUT THE
NATION NEEDS THIS FOOD AND THE
WORLD NEEDS THIS FOOD SP FIVE
FIVE NINE PROVIDES US THE
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY TO PLAN
FOR FUTURE BUT YOU PROTECTED AS
WELL THE BILL REQUEST SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND CANAL
CONVEYANCE REPAIRS OVER THE
COURSE OF TEN YEARS. THAT WILL
PROVIDE A NET BENEFIT TO THE
ENTIRE STATE. IN THE PAST YEAR
THE FRONT WATER AUTHORITY HAS
ASSEMBLED MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM LOCAL AGENCIES AND
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
REPAIRING THE FRANK CURRENT
CANAL. SENATOR FEINSTEIN AND
CONGRESSMAN COSTA. OFFICES ARE
CARRYING FEDERAL ASKED THAT
MAYOR THE ONE I BRING BEFORE
YOU TO FUND CANAL CONVEYANCE
REPAIRS ON THE CALIFORNIA
AQUEDUCT THE DELTA MENDOTA
CANAL THE SALARIES CANAL AND
THE FRANK CURRENT CANAL IT IS
IMPERATIVE WE INVEST IN
REPAIRING THESE CANALS TODAY
EMBRACING OUR LOCAL AND FEDERAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO DO SO CREATING
NEEDED AND GOOD PAYING JOBS
SECURING ACCESS TO DRINKING
WATER FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND ENSURING OUR CAPACITY
TO REMAIN. AND FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECT LASTED ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR TAUGHT OF
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY NINE. WE'RE GOING TO GO
SOONER BARGES FIRST FOLLOWED BY
SYRIANS CENTER BOARDS. MR
PRESIDENT. I'M A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF S. P. FIVE FIVE NINE.
EVERY SO OFTEN WILL HAVE BILLS
THAT ARE BIPARTISAN IN NATURE.
AND EVEN MORE RARELY DO WE HAVE
BILLS THAT BECOME NONPARTISAN.
SP FIVE FIVE NINE HE IS. IN THE
LATTER IT IS SO IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES OUR
OUR WATER SUPPLY OUR DRINKING
WATER SUPPLY OUR AGRICULTURE IN
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE THE SP FIVE
FIVE NINE IS A NONPARTISAN. A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT I
WHOLE HEARTEDLY SUPPORT. WE
HAVE SEEN THE DEVASTATION THAT
IS HAPPENING WITH THIS DROUGHT.
AND JUST THIS WEEK THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES IDENTIFIED ANOTHER
ZERO ALLOCATION. FOR FEDERAL
WATER ON TOP OF THE- MEASLY 5%
ALLOCATION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AT THE STATE LEVEL. ALL OF
THESE CUTBACKS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS OUR CURRENT BUT WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CAPTURE WHAT WATER WE DO HAVE
IMPROPERLY CONVEY IT ACROSS THE
STATE. THE FRANKLIN CANAL IN
THE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS IN LA AND ELSEWHERE
THIS IS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN TO INVEST IN CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE PRO TEM'S.
I PLAN TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S PLAN TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE SO IF WE DON'T
WANT TO CONTINUE. TO RELY ON
WHAT OUR GRANDPARENTS DID IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF OUR FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO INVEST
NOW WE SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
DECADES AGO WITH THIS MOMENT
HAS ARRIVED IN IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO SUPPORT SB
FIVE FIVE NINE BECAUSE- THIS
WATER IS ESSENTIAL. NOT JUST
FOR TOMORROW BUT THE DAY AFTER
IN THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA
COLLEAGUES I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
IN EITHER ON SP FIVE FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU CENTER BORJA SENATOR
NELSON. LADIES AND- IN THE
SENATE THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. I HAVE LIVED MY WHOLE
LIFE FORMING BOTH EAST AND WEST
SIDES OF THE SANDIGANBAYAN AND
THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY. I FEEL
IN THE RAVAGE OF SUBSIDENCE AND
WHAT IT IS. HAS OCCURRED TO.
THE CONVEYANCE SYSTEM OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT. FURTHER A
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND THE
FAILURE OF THE SPILLWAY. AT
OROVILLE DAM. THAT'S WHERE THE
STATE WATER PROJECT ORIGINATES
WHERE THE WATER COMES FROM.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVING TO
BE EVACUATED WHY. BECAUSE THE
DAM FOR FIFTY YEARS HAD NOT
BEEN PROPERLY MAINTAINED. NO
THAT'S STARTING TO HAPPEN IN
FACT AS WE ARE SPEAKING RIGHT
NOW I'M MISSING PARTICIPATION
ON THE CITIZENS ADVISORY
COMMISSION THERE ARE REAL THERE.
STATUTE THAT YOU SUPPORTED HERE
THAT WE PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO
TO ENSURE THAT THE CITIZENS OF
THE AREA. WERE ENGAGED AND
INVOLVED WITH THE AGENCIES OF
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE DAM WAS
MAINTAINED AND REPAIRED AS IT
NEEDED TO BE SO IT DID NOT FAIL.
AND ONE THAT FAIL. OUR WHOLE
SYSTEM. THE SENATORS WRITE THIS
AFFECTION ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
ONE OF THE GREAT FRUSTRATIONS
IS THE AGENCIES OF STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND OTHER
INTERESTS. HAVE INCESSANTLY
OVER THE DECADES DONE
EVERYTHING THEY COULD DO TO
STOP THE REPAIRING OF OUR WATER
PROJECTS. TO STOP THEM. AND IN
FACT. IT'S A SAD FACT. SEVEN
YEARS AGO WE PASSED A WATER
BOND. THAT ALLOWED THE
SUBSTANTIAL MONEY TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR LARGE SURFACE
STORAGE. BECAUSE OF THE ACTIONS
OF AGENCIES AND OTHER ENTITIES
SEVEN YEARS LATER. WE HAVE NOT
STORED ONE GALLON. BUT WHAT. IN
THE THROES OF ANOTHER DROUGHT.
THAT'S PART OF THE EQUATION WE
HAVE NOT ADDRESSED THE
EXCESSIVE REGULATION AND
LITIGATION. BETTER STILL
IMPEDED. BUT KEEP IN MIND
ANOTHER THING THE FUNDAMENTAL
TO THE- WATER PLAN OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OF US. YOU
THINK THIS SHOULD NOT BE
NECESSARY. BUT IN THE SAME YEAR
THAT THE BOND PASSED. I WAS
ABLE TO GET INCORPORATED. AND
TO BOTH THE BOND AND THE NEW
STATE WATER POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE HUMANS HAD A
WATER RIGHT. NOW YOU WOULD
THINK THAT SUCH NONSENSE WHY
WOULD WE EVER EVEN THINK OF
THAT. HISTORICALLY THAT WAS A
GIVEN. THAT IS NOT WHAT
HAPPENED. OVER THREE DECADES.
HUMAN WATER RIGHTS WERE EVEN IF
ANYTHING GREATLY DIMINISHED.
AND NOW THAT IS A PART OF OUR
POLICY AND COMMUNICATION. FROM
THIS LEGISLATURE RELATED TO
REQUEST AUDIT DISTINCT IT THIS
WEEK. THAT HUMANS HAVE WATER.
AND THERE IS NO WATER FOR
HUMANS UNLESS WE MAINTAIN OUR
STORAGE AND A CONVEYANCE
SYSTEMS. THAT'S WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT BILL. AND I MUST
INDICATE IT'S NOT A ONE TIME
THING THIS HAS GOT TO BE
SUSTAINED OVER LONG PERIODS OF
TIME. IT ALSO HELPS ALLEVIATE
THE PROBLEM OF SUBSIDENCE. HOW
BY PROVIDING THAT WATER CONVEY
TO THE STATE WATER PROJECT. ONE
OF THEM CAN BE INJECTED IN DOES
YOUR UNDERGROUND AQUIFERS
ANOTHER IMPORTANT PART THAT
THIS BILL HELPS LARGER NOVEL.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON-
MYSELF THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
APPRECIATE- THE GOOD SENATOR
GIVE US GIVING US INTO OUR
HISTORY WATER PRECIADO VERY
MUCH BUT I WANT TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO SP FIVE FIVE
NINE. AND THIS BILL OF COURSE
IS ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR. AT LEAST THREE
OR TWELVE YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE- I SHOULD
HAVE SERVED ON I SERVED ON THE
ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE I WAS THE
CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE HAVE
ALSO SERVED IN NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THIS ENTIRE TIME
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
BRINGING BACK THE FRANK COME
NOW IT'S AN IMPORTANT RESOURCE
WHEN THAT CANAL WAS CONSTRUCTED
IT REALLY LED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW
AGRICULTURAL CALIFORNIA IS A
VERY IMPORTANT NOT ONLY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
BUT A PROJECT THAT HELP TO
SUPPORT WHAT IS REALLY
CALIFORNIA'S. STRONGEST
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY AND SO WE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO IS PARK
WE NEED TO FINALLY SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND WITH ALL THE
INVESTMENTS WE'VE MADE ON ON
PREVENTING SUBSIDENCE THESE
INVESTMENTS I GUESS WE'LL GO-
WILL BE BUILT ON A MUCH
STRONGER- OF A FOUNDATION AND
THEY WERE IN THE PAST SO-
SENATORS VOTE FOR SP FIVE FIVE
NINE THIS IS A GREAT BILL AND
IT'S TIME TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
IT WITH THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY NINE. SEEING NONE SENATOR
TITLE WHICH I TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MY PESIDENT COLLEAGUES I
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU HEARD
ABOUT- IF IT PERHAPS THROUGH
THE NEW YORK WALL AND THE NEW
YORK ARE REGARD THE CITY OF
CORK AND HOW IT'S SUNKEN-
SIGNIFICANT OVER THE YEARS AND-
THAT IS. DUE TO THE LACK OF
WATER WATER IS SO IMPORTANT TO
OUR REGION BUT REALLY TO THE
ENTIRE STATE AND CLIMATE CHANGE
IS IMPACTING- AND WILL INCREASE
THE WATER AT CHALLENGESTHAT WE
HAVE NOT JUST IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE ENTIRE WEST IS
IN A DROUGHT AND WE ARE ABOUT
TO BE HITTING EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU'RE VERY WHAT WHAT I WOULD
REFER TO AS A CLIMATE DISASTER.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AND- GET
THE NECESSARY REPAIRS DONE AS
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE OTHERWISE I
MEAN WE'RE ALREADY FACING VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES I AND FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK. I WAS LAST
FRIEND ABOUT. THANK YOU SIR
TAKE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA ARC HI AT KINS. EIGHT
HI BECKER. HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY. FIVE DOT. HI TORONTO
HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER I COULD
DOLLARS HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LLEVA HI LYNN MON.
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S HI MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
VOGUE HI PAM. HI FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
HI STERN. NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI
WHAT KASKY. NO WINNER HI WELL I
SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN AT KINS.
CAN LONGER. LIMONIUM STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY FOUR DOES ONE
MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS ARE GOING
BACK A BIT IN THE FILE TO FILE
AND ONE SIXTY SEVEN THIS WILL
BE CENTER STERN THIS WILL BE
OUR LAST FILE ITEM OF THE DAY.
SENATOR STERN IS ON SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY ONE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY
ONE BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT IS B. FIVE FIVE ONE
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC VEHICLE
AUTHORITY. WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP STRATEGIC PLANNING
AND PARTNERSHIPS TO BUILD ON
THE GREAT WORK THAT THE STATE
IS ALREADY PUT INTO OUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE PROGRAMS. IN
BOTH ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS AND OTHER
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE. WE CAN
SEE MORE PETROLEUM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER
NATION ON THE PLANET SO FOR THE
U. S. AND CHINA. CALIFORNIA
WE'RE A NATION WE BE NUMBER
THREE. SIX MIDDLE CLASS BUDGET.
WE'RE HAVING A SUPER COMMUTE
ALL OVER THE PLACE TO MAKE
THEIR LIVES WORK THE AVERAGE
FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA MAKING
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
LESS. IS SPENDING MORE ON THEIR
TRANSPORTATION. AND FOOD AND
HEALTH CARE COMBINES. THIS IS
NOT JUST AN ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE
OR CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUE THIS IS
ABOUT THE ECONOMICS OF MAKING
IT IN CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED
LEADERSHIP AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS TO BRING THE BEST
BUSINESSES INTO CALIFORNIA. TO
INCREASE MANUFACTURING TO BUILD
OUT THE LITHIUM VALLEY THAT WE
WANT TO NOT OUTSOURCE OUR
BATTERY PRODUCTION BUT IN
SOURCE IT. WENT WORKING
CALIFORNIANS DO THAT WORK. WE
HAVE A LOT OF INVESTMENT GOING
INTO THIS SPACE AND WE THINK
THIS AT THE ALREADY AND THIS
STRUCTURE WILL PROVIDE THE
THROUGH PUT THAT WE NEED AND I
WANT TO PAY DUE RESPECT TO WHAT
THE NEW SIM ADMINISTRATION'S
BEEN DOING. WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AT THE
AIRPORT AND THAT THE CDC- BUT
WE THINK THIS BILL WILL WILL
SET THE PACE AND PUT CALIFORNIA
TRACK TO NOT JUST BE. A CLIMATE
LEADER BUT TO BE THE MOST
COMPETITIVE ECONOMY ON THE
PLANET I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ALSO MY JOINT AUTHOR OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR HIS TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP ON THE MATTER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SB
FIVE FIFTY ONE. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY BRIEFLY MISSED PER. MEMBER
AS THE JOINT AUTHOR WORKING IN-
IN CONJUNCTION THIS MATTER I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT. IN ADDITION
TO. THE INDIVIDUAL CAR USERS TO
ME THAT ONE OF THE CRITICAL
THINGS THAT WE'VE MISSED IN THE
STATE. AND MY HOPE WITH RESPECT
TO THIS MEASURE IS TO DEAL WITH
COMMERCIAL USE. IF WE CAN
COORDINATE OUR ACTIVITIES WE
CAN AVOID SPENDING TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. WORKING WITH THE
VARIOUS LOGISTICS PEOPLE OF THE
MAJOR TRANSPORT COMPANIES TO
HELP US SITE AROUND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE ENERGY
STATIONS FUELING STATIONS THAT
WORK FOR THEM. IN TERMS OF THE
DISTANCES THAT THEY DRIVE AND
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY WHAT
IS THE RESULT OF A COORDINATED
EFFORT BY THE STATE IN ADDITION
TO. INDIVIDUAL CAR USE. BUT TO
BE ABLE TO DRAMATICALLY EXPAND
THE USE OF ELECTRIC TRUCKS IN
DELIVERY AND I THINK THIS IS A
BIG STEP TOWARD THAT. AN
ASTEROID. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON. SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY ONE. SENATOR ARCHULETA-
YES THANK YOU MUCH FOR I'D LIKE
TO- CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS FORWARD AND ONCE
AGAIN AS A REMINDER THAT WE
HAVE TO ALSO REMEMBER THAT THE
FUEL CELL HYDROGEN IT MUST BE
PART OF OUR INTERVIEW PACKAGE
FOR THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE CAN'T
DO IT WITH ELECTRICITY ALONE WE
HAVE TO OPEN UP THAT TREASURE
CHEST OF ENERGY TO INCLUDE FUEL
CELL- AND I AND I HOPE THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO THAT IN
THE FUTURE. BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
NEED IT ALL WE HEARD ABOUT A
HEAVY VEHICLES TRUCKS BUSES AND
I THINK THE FUEL CELL HYDROGEN
WOULD BE THE ANSWER TO THAT AND
LET'S CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THAT TOGETHER AND WITH THAT I
URGE- I VOTE THANK YOU SIR
ARCHER LET ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE STORE
AND YOU HAVE A- BRIEF CLOSE
FORCE. A YES THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PICO RIVERA. AND
WE'RE TRYING TO BEALL IN HERE
ON ALL TECHNOLOGIES. AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SIR SIR
MEMBERSTHIS IS OUR LAST FILE
ITEM BUT WE DO HAVE BUSINESS
TO. CONCLUDE AFTER THIS SO-
PLEASE REMAIN AVAILABLE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
BASED. BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY NO DOT. HI TORONTO I
AIKMAN HI GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I
GROW. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO. HI JONES NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
TRIO OF BOTH. HI PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI SECRETARY CALL THE APPS
MEMBERS WERE ALTERED ONE TIME.
ATKINS EIGHT NO. PORGES MON.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE IT KNOWS SIX
MAJOR PASSES. SENATORS WERE
GONNA MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS I BELIEVE A
RECOGNIZING SENATOR MCGUIRE
FIRST CINEMA GLARE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT I'LL BE
THE ONE FOR WEEKEND SIR I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST MOVING FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY SP TWO EIGHTY
FIVE TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SENATOR BECKER. PRESIDENT
PLEASE PULL UP PULL FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR SP FIVE
OH FOUR FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BAKER CENTER
MELENDEZ IN THE BACK FOR A
PURPOSE D. RICE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY EIGHT I'M MAKING A
MOTION TO WITHDRAW AS C. R.
FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS IT HAS
BEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
DAYS NOW SINCE THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR KEVIN AND SHUT DOWN THE
STATE. ALASKA MICHIGAN NORTH
DAKOTA OKLAHOMA WISCONSIN HAVE
ALL LIFTED THEIR STATE OF
EMERGENCY ORDERS WITH FOURTEEN
OTHER STATES FOLLOWING SUIT BY
THE END OF THE MONTH. FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY ONE DAYS THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY HAVE
VOLUNTARILY AGREED TO
SUBORDINATE THEMSELVES TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF OUR
GOVERNMENT WE ARE CO. EQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND I
THINK IT IS TIME WE STEP BACK
INTO THAT ROLE. I ASK FOR YOUR
I. THAT. CENTER MELINDA'S THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT THE
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR NO VOTE SENATOR
MELINDA IS ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN NO ARCHULETA NO
ACTIONS BAIT FIVE BECKER NO
FORGES HI BRADFORD. NO. BY ADAM
NO COURTESY. NO DALLY HI DOG.
NO THERE ARE SO. NO EGGMAN NO
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ NO GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG HI. I HURTS BERG I
DON'T KNOW. WAY SO NO HER TADO
NO JONES I CAN LONGER NO
LAYERED. NO LLEVA NO THE MON.
REQUIRE. NO MELINDA'S I MEN. NO
NEWMAN NO NIELSEN. HI A SHOW OF
BOTH. I CAN NO PERSON TINO NO
ROCK NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER NOTE
STERN NO AMBERG KNOW WHAT KASKI.
YEAH NO WINNER NO WILKE HI.
HIGHS NINE NOS TWENTY NINE
MAJOR FAILS. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE US TODAY.
SENATOR BATES THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE PLACED WE WILL
RECONVENE TUESDAY JUNE FIRST AT
TWELVE NOON NOTE TWELVE NOON.
THANK YOU SENATOR EIGHT WEEKS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES LAYS IN
GERMAN PLEASE. HAVE ENJOY YOUR
THREE DAY WEEKEND KEEPING IN
MIND MEMORIAL DAY AND THE
MEMORY OF THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN
THE ULTIMATE SCRIFICE FOR OUR
COUNTRY. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED. MEMBERS
WE WILL BEAT RECONVENE ON
TUESDAY TUESDAY JUNE FIRST AT
TWELVE NOON TWELVE NOON ON
TUESDAY JUNE FIRST THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AND HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND.